let me welcome you to
my talk titled the next generation
simulation tool for the characterization
and optimization
of gas and or steered bioreactors
let's have a look at the market of
pharmaceuticals the top 10
active pharmaceutical ingredients by
sales volume
were 10 so-called small
molecules in 2006. in 2018 already seven
out of those top ten api were so-called
active biopharmaceutical ingredients
and these biopharmaceutical ingredients
are produced
in bioreactors the complex processes
in those reactors have to be designed
and controlled but this is currently
done only based on
empirical knowledge there is a lack of
deeper process understanding
simulations could not provide this
deeper process understanding but they're
expensive
require experts and take months
this is a classic simulation workflow
the steps in red
are especially complicated and time
consuming like
choosing the appropriate calculation
models and choosing the boundary
conditions
with our simulation software with our
approach
you can specify your operating
conditions as easy as with microsoft
excel
you can skip all the complicated steps
with the knowledge we implemented into
our program yet
the full physics are not only included
they are based on physical first
principles
and then you enter our numerical server
which runs on the
which runs on the gpu which is about 10
times
faster than the classic cpu solvers
then you get a huge pile of data and to
get your interesting results
out of this huge pile of simulation data
this is called post-processing
we have a partially automated process
for you
no so let's go on the road to product
dvd as we
like to call it we have the operating
conditions
and the geometrical conditions of the
reactor
and we want to get information about the
productivity
of the reactor the first step
is always the fluid simulation together
with the
air bubble simulation and this is then
the basis
for the substrate calculations or the
mixing
the calculation of the shear stress
because some of these
cells or microorganisms are shear
sensitive
and the temperature calculation
based on those models um you can either
have
information about starvation or
oversupply of nutrients
or the depth rate because of shear
stress and
of course the temperature this all is
included into a biological novel
and this gives us the productivity
so let's look first on the fluid
simulation
the fluid simulation you have the
problem of the different scales involved
you have the
scale where you have single bubbles
rising in
in the reactor you have the miso scale
where the bubble plumes
which behave differently and you have
the device scaled
for us interesting is the device scale
and this means we need to have
models for the meso and microscale
effects
the model for the fluid flow fluid
calculation is the largest boltzmann
simulation the lattice boltzmann
consists of two steps
the collision and the streaming step on
each
of the simulation nodes the reactor
is written into a regular grid so there
are no
adapted grid cells and on each
grid cell there are 19 density
distribution functions
called f values and those f
values are then in a collision step
brought a tiny bit
towards the equilibrium state and this
is the right side of this
formula on the left side of this formula
there is the streaming step where these
f values are brought
to the next node where they are pointing
at so
for example there were one a vector
is transported to the next node on the
right side
if you then sum up all of these f values
you get the density
and if you sum up the f values weighted
by their
direction and divide by the density
then you get the microscopic velocity
and because we only need information on
uh the node and not some huge matrix
which has to be inverted
this is called a very um localized
method and this makes it ideal to be
implemented on a graphic card with cuda
and c plus cuda is an extension of c
plus plus
for talking to the gpu and
this code this method can be solved on a
single workstation
you do not need a high performance
cluster the turbulence modeling is of
course
important because all the or most of the
processes inside such bioreactors are
highly turbulent and
we use a les model this means we model
all the tubulins
down to the scale of one calculation
cell and for this
subgrid scale so what's happening inside
such a simulation box
we use this magarinsky model to model
this
also formally you can see here
for the bubble calculation you see here
an
animation with this bubble calculation
which we use in a branching model we
track every single bubble
in the reactor and
to get the movement of those bubbles
we solve the newton's equations of
motion this means
um we calculate all the forces which act
on a single bubble
and then get the acceleration of the
bubble in this time step
and therefore with the velocity at the
beginning of the time step we have
can calculate the velocity and the
position at the end of the time step
but there is also a feedback force from
the bubbles
to the fluid and this means you can also
simulate
bubble columns where you have no stirrer
where the fluid is mixed
only by the bubbles
and as the bubble number is very high
in such reactors we have a parcel
approach
this means we group bubbles together
which have similar properties and we
then follow one representative
bubble for the reactor
one of the first things bubbles do when
they move around
is that they collide with each other
and when a collision happens there are
two ways
what can happen either to separate again
or they form a large bubble and the
large bubble is only formed
when the contact time is longer than the
film rupture time so this tiny little
fluid film between those two contacting
bubbles
um how long this takes to rupture
is compared to the contact time if the
film
rupture time is shorter than the contact
hem then a big bubble is formed this is
called coalescence
if the contact time is shorter than the
film rupture time then the bubbles
only exchange momentum and separate
again
but bubbles do not only get bigger they
also get smaller
and in our model the main source of
bubble breakup are turbulence
tubulin eddies in the same size of the
bubbles because
large it is only transport the bubbles
around
and small and this do not have enough
energy
to break up the bubble
all this together then
can enable a fluid
and bubble um bioreactor simulation
and we of course we have to validate
that
and we did validation experiments with a
150 litre
pilot scale plexiglass fermenter which
we had in our
lab and this was measured with a
conductivity probe a needle conductivity
probe
and we compared the hold up at different
locations in the reactor
to our from the experiment
to the simulations and we get good
results good
simulation results which are very
comparable to the experiment
what is a new feature of our simulation
code is the
simulation of the flooding the reactive
flooding the flooding detection
if you have a stream of gas then
the steerer if it's too slow it cannot
distribute the bubbles throughout
the reactor but the bubbles flow around
the steerer and the steering turns in a
in a gas bloom
if the um steering speed
if the velocity of the steerer is high
enough then is
it is able to distribute the bubbles
again
and this is then the point where the
flooded stays
goes over into a normal operation state
and this is very important
for for the industry because you lose a
lot of
efficiency if your stereo is flooded
how do we do that we have a civilian
director
zone around each steerer and if
there is a net inflow in this zone
and this is at low steering rates
you see here at the bottom then you know
that your bubbles um create the
circulation which creates
um inflow towards the steera
and if the steerer is effective again
and pushes the bubbles
outwards um then suddenly
the flow in this cylinder changes and
goes to the outside
and this is when the transition from the
flooded state
to normal operation state is happening
and we have compared this um
with experimental values of vamos
captain and we
see that we have a very good agreement
with the experimental
values
so now we have done the
fluid simulation and the simulation of
the bubbles we can
move on to the distribution of dissolved
substances and one example of such a
simulation of dissolved substances you
can
see here um where a species
is injected at the top and then
distributed
throughout the reactor homogenized by
the steerer
especially interesting is here that we
have a tilted steerer
and this is important if you want to
simulate a single use bioreactors
where the engine sits on the side
of the reactor top with
this simulation of the species transport
we can then either do mixing times
if you inject a species or a salt
which is then homogenized throughout the
reactor
you can calculate the 95 mixing time
this means when
um every uh the
average above of all cells
reaches 95 of the
average after a long simulation time
and this can be compared um for example
to the measurements of
c and we see that we have very good
agreement
uh in this mixing times but what is
especially interesting um for the
industry
and for aerated bioreactors is the ka
value
for the k value you have to get your
fluid simulation right
you have to get your bubble stimulation
right you have to do the
mass transfer of the oxygen from the
bubbles to the fluid
and you have to do the transportation of
the
dissolved oxygen throughout the reactor
because this
again affects the mass transport and
all that comparing gives us a good
agreement between the experimental value
and the simulated value especially if
you think about the fact that
uh kla values in in experiments
is very hard to measure and you get a
certain kind of
error bar already in the experiments
this means
um the 20 deviation which you see
in the higher guest cases uh
is a good agreement between experimental
and simulated values
but not only a dissolved um substance
can be transported around the reactor
also um an oil phase can be simulated
and for oil droplets it's not very
useful to do a lagrangian simulation
where you follow every oil droplet
but for the high number of oil droplets
it's more useful to do a population
balance this means you divide the
reactor
in certain areas and
then you calculate what is flowing in
into this area what is flowing outwards
of this area
and what breakup and and coalescence
of these oil droplets is happening
inside those boxes
and then you can compare those results
also with measurements
done for example woodsardy
and you see here that the open
boxes and triangles and circles
are the measurement values and the color
colored lines
are our simulations and you see a very
good agreement
especially if you think about the fact
that we have no
tuning parameters so this simulation is
not tuned
to to this specific
validation experiment we can do all
we can compare
different validation experiments like we
have done at the bottom
and get similar good similarly good
results
here on the picture you see um the
distribution
or the the the reactor
um which is divided into those boxes i
talked about
and um you easily see that in the area
around the reactor
around the steerer there is a lower
solder diameter
of the oil droplets because of the
high turbulence intensity and in the
areas below
the gas furniture there is a higher
south
southern diameter of the um oil bubbles
because there is not a lot of fluid
motion
happening there so coming from the
substrate
now to the shear stress the shear stress
is a value which you get directly out of
your fluid flow field simulation
but what you can do here is that um
you simulate lifelines of massless
tracer particles
these represent cells or microorganisms
in the reactor
and these are then followed around
the they're they are followed around
through the path inside the reactors and
you can record
these lifelines so what do they see what
do they feel
um what consideration of oxygen
concentration of nutrients
do they see in their journey throughout
the reactor
and then you can record this
for the number of massless tracer
particles
we use a representative number because
the
um number of uh
of uh cells inside
uh real bioreactors would be just too
high
to assimilate them also with the most
modern processors
but we chose a representative number
of those massless tracer particles to
capture
every physical detail inside the reactor
and for even a part of these
of this representative number uh the
lifelines can be recorded
and an example of these lifelines you
can see here
where the shear stress um is um
recorded over time and you'll see that
if you have such
spikes in the shear stress uh this is
when
one of these tracer particles
um hits the steerer
you can not only record the shear stress
but also
considerations of dissolved oxygen
concentration of dissolved substrate
and if you have a biological model
where you can also model your production
of
co2 then you can also record
the concentration of carbon dioxide for
example
or you can also record your rate of
product conversion if you have a
biological cell-based model in place
but you cannot not only follow one or
a representative number of these
massless tracer particles
around the reactor but you can do
snapshots
of all these tracer particles at a
certain time
and this can be then shown in a
histogram
as shown here
these uh spherics are not
especially interesting um in in this
example
but it is very important when you for
example compare
reactors reactors of different sizes
because then you also can do these
snapshots
at the classy steady state and compare
them
in those histograms and can choose for
example
in a process transfer the
edl target reactor if you have a
production reactor that is already
running
the same you can do in a scalar process
where you have your benchtop reactor
where you know that
productivity is high and you have a
target production scale reactor and you
can do those snapshots
and those histograms and compare the two
different
reactors the same is true if you do a
process characterization so from a large
scale
back to a small scale reactor where you
have your scaled down models you can
test those scaled down moments
with those lifelines with those massless
traces we also implemented
a cumulative energy um
where we plot the energy which
is experienced by a single cell
or microorganism when they float through
the reactor
and every time there is a steep increase
in this cumulative energy um you know
that
the cell has hit a zero or is in the
zone of high
shear stress for
um to get an idea how long these
simulations take
this was a very quick simulation with
this bubble column
and those um again massless tracer
particles which float around the color
is the shear stress
which they experience and
from the beginning of the setup over the
calculation over the simulation to the
creation of this video which you see
here
it took uh 20 minutes of all time so
it's very fast very quick
if you have a very large reactors to be
simulated
reactors up to 250 cubic meters
the simulation time can extend two weeks
but
it doesn't take months or even longer
so for the last model we have the
temperature heating cooling
is especially important in reactors
where
the product conversion generates heat
and
we can for example simulate a heating
jacket
and an example of heating of a
bioreactor with a heating jacket you can
see here
and also with the temperature
distribution
which then are is experienced
by the cells or microorganisms
what we can also do is a two bottle heat
exchanger which
are dropped which are built inside those
reactors
and we only do the um outside
the cylindrical outside of this tube
bottle heat exchanger
and these cylinders here in blue
have a certain porosity that the
velocity resistance or the flow
resistance
of these cylinders is the same
as the tube bundle heat exchanger if
they would have
been simulated with each single
tube
what is also important is that we can
simulate
um those cells or microorganisms
that generate heat and you see here that
when you inject those cells
at the bottom of the reactor to disperse
slowly inside the reactor
and if you switch on then the the heat
generation we
um set a value of 0.1
watts which is very high but this was
just for
as a showcase then you see how the
reactor
is slowly heating up because of the heat
generated by those tracer particles
cells and micronus
and with all that we are now ready
to go into a biological model to a cell
based biological model
those models are currently
developed and researched and with those
biological models we can then um get our
productivity
and what's even more important we can
optimize the productivity
in silico with the simulation and um
take fewer experiments and in a shorter
time
so what is the benefit for the companies
what is
your benefit out of those simulations
your fear trials
at the process characterization state
and have a much easier identification of
critical
process parameters and this is also
already published
that the savings can amount here to
three hundred thousand euro
to 1 million euro you have a faster time
to market because you do
can do experiments in silico and you can
do
faster process transfers for example
with the shear rate comparison
as i showed earlier you can have more
data for the regulatory approval process
including also the extreme ends of your
operating range
and you can support design decisions
where
you can for example compare different
stereo heights
because the simulation time was reduced
from months to hours
so this is a useful time for
engineering processes the last thing is
that you can do faster
troubleshooting and have a deeper
process understanding
due to the use of stimulation
so i want to thank you this is the
team at the tue grass which is
developing the software
my name is kristen bits please
contact me if you have any
any further interest any questions or if
you are interested in a collaboration
or if you want to test out this
simulation software
thank you